بريطانيين كان شو يسوون يبون يستفيدون من
الخدمات القد اول السلع التي تنتجها الصين
من البورسلين من الشاي من الحليب على شان
تاخذها تشتريهم من الصين توديهم اوروبا
على الاستهلاك المحلي بس الصيام كان عندها
اي اهتمام
البريطانيه عبر الشركات الموجوده
تروح تنتج الافيون
في الهند
الماده المخدره
وفيها ادمان
وتخلي الناس كلهم كساله وانت حطني انتاجك
ولين الامبراطور الصيني قال لحظه انتم
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن
هو النموذج الاول
الامريكي والاقتصاد الصيني
ثاني تكون في 20 30 بتكون الاولى فالكل
متفق عليها الاولى النظيفه يقول تطيعكم
ودي اعرف ليه يتوقع ان تبقى امريكا الاولى
رغم كل الصراعات الداخليه الامريكيه
والاستقطاب الحزب الحاد ورغم الحجم همم
الضخم للدين العام في امريكا فاا ضيفي
بسام نور الرئيس التنفيذي للاستثمارات
البديله في درايه همم للاستثمار قبل ان
نبدا كاس العالم حريقه سعوديه حريقه وتابع
معظم اللي تنتج القنوات من تحليل ونقاشات
والصراحه صحيح يعني منحاز لكن لا افضل من
كره كاس المرتده وحديد خالد القحطاني وعبد
الله العيسي همم في هذا
الحلقات موجوده على اي من برامج الفات كاس
او على اليوتيوب
لنبدا
انا اجيت الرياض في نهايه 2013 سنه
جيت الحين
هذه الامور الي نحن نشوفها انا وانت فلان
وفلان تغيرات البسيطه بس الي قاعد في
القطاع المالي حكم تخصصي نشوف الامور
الاصلاحات الهيكليه قاعد يصير في الاقتصاد
نفسه من ابسط مثال قوانين النظام
في 2016 17
الشركات خارج السعوديه بسبب الانضمام
موجوده كلها
[موسيقى]
يعني مثلا ان ان الفئات المختلفه للاسهم
ما كانت موجوده والحقوق التصويت الموجود
شيء ثاني طيب شنو النظام ما كان في نظام
السعوديه يعني اذا انت تملك شركه
انك تفصلها عن كيان مستقل
ما كانت واضحه فيها تساؤلات كثيره 2008
محلول ما في اليه معينه
ما بداوا يحلونها الا الي طلع نظام الفلاس
قبل سنه ونصف
تذكرون عليهم
واحنا نعرف السوق قاعد تنحل هذه المشاكل
هذه الامور كلها جيده
سنتين قدام
غير المؤمنين بان هذه العود قبل التحقيق
في المرحله المفصليه في حياتها
اداره تغير او بتنهار
لان سكان الصين امور كثيره تحتاج اصلاحات
ما كانت تتم جي واحد قال لا اعرف شنو مكان
من الخطر الموجود وشنو الاصلاحات المفروض
الناس يسويها وكانت عند الشجاعه ان ينفذها
وحتى نفذها ما كانت بالطريقه القديمه
كانت عندك فيلم امكانيات كانت كبيره في
السعوديه دائما امكانيه كانت موجوده بس ما
حد كان يشتغل هذه الاستغلال الصحيح حتى
الان اشتغل في دبي كنت اييه الرياض حق
الشغل
[موسيقى]
اللي في السعوديه
اللي تحتاجه السعوديه انها تقوم من النوم
كان ساكن في دبي
هل دبي بالظل ولا ابو ظبي والقطار ولا
بحرين العملاق
بيسحب كل شيء
كل الاعمال
الشركات الموجوده الشركات اللي هي في
البيت
عدد كبير منهم لخدمه السعوديه كحكومه
وكشركات وكثتثمارات مش كثير من الشركات
الماليه والبنوك اداره تسع سنوات
يلا خلاص
همم
ليش قاعدين يدورونش من دبي لان اول ما
كانت في القوانين لتسمح لهم انه يفتحون
مكاتب الحين بدها القوانين تتغير مده
البنوك والشركات الاستثماريه عالميه بدات
تفتح محلات همم
وبدات تنفيذ الكثير من القوانين الا تسهل
هذه العمليه غير شركات الطاقه مش اكثر من
شركات الطاقه اللي تقدم خدمات حق ارامكو
وصابك كل خبر موجودين في البحرين او بال-
بس كنت الاسبوع الماضي في دبي
وجلس مدري ايش اللي خلاني كذا بس جالسه
طالع يعني كل الناس اللي في دبي من كل
العالم
كلهم ما عندهم اساس يربطهم في دبي الشيء
الجوله اجله
اااه
وناجحه والناس جايه مبسوطه الناس
طالع القى مثلا برج خليفه
اغلب الشركات الثانيه
هي اللي بنت كل المدينه
بنت المولات بنات القطار بنات الشوارع
بنات المستشفيات بينما لو طالع مثلا في
الشكل الاقتصادي بالنسبه
نيويورك بدات تستمر جابت
طلعت مدينه طبيعيه
اللي في دبي ما في ولايه اقتصادي ممكن
يقتنع انه هذا الشكل منطقي ان الدوله كل
شيء
وان الناس بتجي مو الناس اللي بتسويه
وبعدين يتنافسون في ما بينهم كل واحد يسوي
احسن ومع ذلك ناجح يعني فم
ستغرق كيف قدرت انها تسوي هذا الشيء وهل
هو منطقي اقتصاديا انه يصير بهذا الشكل
ومنطقي جدا كيف اقول لك
واجب الدوله تدخل في الاقتصاد بصوره عامه
نتكلم عنها هي تكون مسؤوله عن القطاعات
الحيويه غير طبيعيه هذا شيء ما يطلع لك
فلوس الخاص
انواع الاستثمارات اللي مردودها اما يكون
على فتره طويله 20 سنه 30 سنه قطاع الخاص
ما يتحملها او مردود يكون غير مالي
تسويقي
البرج خليفه
علشان يسوون فلوس علشان يطلعون البرزون
اسم دبي
[موسيقى]
20 سنه 30 سنه اطول منهم
20 30
متى 2010 2011 12 13 الى 16 بنت عدد كبير
من الشوارع والتقاطعات والقناه شنو عليه
كل اللفه 4 ريال 4 دراهم سخونه عليه
الحين قاعد يسوون النظام سالك اللي عندهم
يسوون
مردود
12 سنه
الضرائب الموجود في نيويورك
في امريكا
اساطير يحتاج نقل العام تعليم كلها الامور
من الضرائب احنا ما عندنا ضرائب نفس
الكميه الموجوده ولكن عندنا الدخل من شنو
بترول
فيعود هذا النقل
مو مرتفعه من الحكومه عندها مصدر دخل اخر
السعوديه
تروح اجمع لكل يقول لهم تعال بنبني ويا
بعض مدينه في نيويورك
[موسيقى]
لان عندها القدره وعندها الصبر وعندها
نظره ليس فقط نظره ماليه عندها نظره
تسويقيه جوده الحياه والى خلق اوكي
شارع البحر الاحمر في قطاع الضيافه نحن
الضيافه لو تروح في دبي
على البحر
[موسيقى]
تمام طيب في اسئله كثيره لا ما نعرف
اجابتها كيف تقدر تجذب الاجانب النيون
عندك شو الخدمات اللي بتقدمها هالجميع
الخدمات بتكون متاحه ولا بعضها الاجوبه ما
حد يعرف الحين بس النظره النظره
الاقتصاديه الشموليه من الدوله
السياحه الداخليه
وتاخذ عليها طبعا الضرائب وغيره ودور
الاقتصاد ودور القطاع الخاص انه هو يتحرك
هو اللي يعني كل الابراج الموجوده في
امريكا او حتى في بريطانيا
اخر بس
هذا شكل مثالي لانه القطاع الخاص يشتغل
الحكومه تشريف وتشرع فقط فاذا القطاع
الخاص فيها في انه هذا مثالي مثالي حتى
نيو
همم يعني مثلا في امريكا في الظاهر انه
مؤسس همم جت اتوقع انها جت ناس والله بس
اللي انه الواحد من الشركات
الحين جالسه يبني مدينه جديده مستقبليه ما
ادري بكم ب 500 مليار برضه
القطع الخاص قادر على انه يبنيه
على هذا الموضوع ما في ولا مثال في اي
مدينه في العالم انه تم انشاءها او
الاستثمار فيها بشكل كبير في البدايه عن
طريق القطاع الخاص
حتى المدن الطبيه مثلا في مدينه الطبيه
معروفه هناك كانت عن طريق الدعم الحكومي
على الاقل بدا الانتاج
في مدينه مشهوره في كوريا الجنوبيه نفس
الموضوع الحكومه شرعت ولكن فتحت القطاع
الخاص واحنا عندنا مشاكل كبيره
وعلى التاريخ نشوف المدن الجديده اذا ما
اكون وراءها دعم حكومي هائل ما بتنجح مثلا
روسيا السابقه
مدينه جديده
والدعم
المشاريع طيب الدعم في انواع مختلفه كيفيه
الدعم يكون بعضهم احيانا دعم نقدي
نحكومه اوكي انا مثل امريكا
حيويه حق امريكا
تقدر
احنا قرر عندنا سياره كهربائيه عندنا شركه
قاعده في السياره الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر في
تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه
وذكاء سلوشن سباي اس تي سي
[موسيقى]
لو حتى نروح نشوف
الدعم اللي قاعد تقدمها طيب ما عندنا شيء
تقدر تبني عليها
يعني كحجم اقتصاد وكفكره وقت تجربه لو انت
قلت اي شيء اي فكره اللي عندك في امريكا
هل في جدول منها ولا لا بتحصل الامثله من
السياحه من طاقه من خدمات الماليه من اي
نوع من عندك حكم حجمها
تاريخها كلها الامور موجوده
طيب
غير موجود كثير من الامور غير موجود
في
في لوت لو تاخذ كم منظور عام
شوف الحكومه قعدت تخارج من الشركات اللي
اثبتت فعاليتها وادت الدور المفروض ان
الديره تطلع منه
الموضوع تداول الحكومه بدات عن طريق صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه وتخرج منه وفي عده
امثله موجوده في السوق كيف ان بعد ما شركه
تنظيف
افكار جديده
سير سيارات الكهربائيه على فكره جديده
القشه اللي مو موجوده غير موضوع النيوم
غير موضوع البحر الاحمر غير المشاريع
الاخرى الموجوده
شو النظام في الخليج هل هو نظام راسمالي
ولا اشتراكي لا هذا ولا هذا ولا هذا اعتقد
في احترام الملكيه الخاصه
في دور كبير للحكومه في اقتصاد الدوله
تاريخيه واسباب محليه يعني
عدد سكانها نحن صغيره
انت تحتاج عند السكان يكبر
استثمار اذا عندك
حجم سكان مليون
شو الفكره اللي بتسوي فيها يعني
غير ما عندك دوله بحجم سكان 200 مليون ولا
300 300 مليون ففي السابق جميع الاموال من
النفط ولله الحمد يتم ادارتها عن طريق
الاستثمار في سندات الخزينه عندك الكويت
عندهم صندوق السياديه
بحرين قطار عمان السعوديه من اجل استثمار
هذا الفائض ما عندك فرص شو بتسوي فيه
الامور
في الدوله في المشاريع اللي تقدر تنفع
الدوله
هو اقرب من الراس الماليه من الشيوعيه هو
النظام عجين يعني
لا يوجد الحين اي شيء
هذا يمكن اخر تطبيق له كان في امريكا في
نهايه القرن التاسع عشر بدايه القرن
العشرين هذا كان اخر تطبيق لكن النظام راس
مالي
بعد تغيرت كل فتره وفتره يعني في امريكا
صار العكس من الحكومه كل سنه تدخل اكثر
[موسيقى]
نتكلم لكن خلي الشركات
الخاصه
في امريكا
وكان عندك الجزء الاخر
الحزب الاخر
حكومه
الجمهور الحزبه جمهوري هذا يختلف عن حزب
الجمهوريه
اللي صار ان حتى في البتاع اللي كان في
سرعه على الموضوع في بدايات انتهى لا نخلي
دول الامريكيه
انه دول الدوره دول الامريكيه في تلك
الفتره والدفاع عن الاراضي الامريكيه
والحروب
[موسيقى]
الدوله الامريكيه كانت الموضوع ابعد
الدوله عن الحياه العامه والخاصه بشكل
كبير
لشوي شوي شوي شوي
خصوصا مع المشاكل اللي كانت تصيد الاقتصاد
الامريكي
حكم عدم وجود
نظام مركزي للحمايه حمايه الاموال
مستودعات تدخل
الحكومه العده مرات لانه البنك المركزي
الامريكي
ثلاث مرات كل مره يطلع يستمر 10 سنوات
في القطاع الخاص لازم مسكر
الوحوش الكون
والنظام الفدرالي الاحتياطي موجود حاليا
في 1913
قبل الحرب العالميه الاولى سنه واحده
الفكره الاقتصادي
اساسا تروح حق
انجليزي
[موسيقى]
القطاع الخاص هو اللي يعرف به لانه هو حط
فلوسه في الموضوع الثاني
انتشار عصر عصر الاكتشاف اللي صار في
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
من امريكا لاوروبا يبيعون في اسيا
تشجع على هذا النظام
جزء من مدرسه شيكاغو ان
كانت تردد فعل للامور الحكومه
كانت تتدخل يعني حتى لو في
1931 كان نصير انتخابات واللي قبله
سالوا قبلك طيب شنو برنامج الانتخابات
عشان نطلع اتصال
الموجوده ولا شيء
الاقتصاد بحل نفسه بنفسه
م الطريقه الصحيحه بده شوي شوي طلع قوانين
جديده جديده من الضمان الاجتماعي من الدعم
قطاع الاسكان والى خلق عمل اشياء كثير
خلال تلك الفتره يعني بدات تدخل الحكومه
بشكل كبير في الاغتصاب دائما
ما في شيء دايما صاحب دائما
غلطان
الاستثمارات اللي ما يتحملها القطاع الخاص
الحين الجزء الثالث هذه اعتمد من دوله
لدوله
القطاع الخاص ممكن يتحملها في امريكا بس
في السعوديه ما يتحملها
ممكن السعوديه تحمل في امريكا ما اتحملها
يعني مثلا يعني يمكن تقدر تقول ان شركه
ارامكو الحكومه
في الطاقه تقول ارامكو تسوي في امريكا في
ارامكو
فيها شركه متعدده الجنسيات يشتغلون في
موضوع التنقيب عن النفط وتحط عندهم شروط
شركات تقدر
بيكون اكثر جدوله من وجود شركه تملكه
الدوله
[موسيقى]
او يكون حيوي
بالنسبه للاقتصاد
النفط يعتبر بالنسبه لنا هذا
الامن القومي بالنسبه
للذهب الي عندنا لشركات اجنبيه تتحكم فيه
كيف تتحكم بالشركات المحليه هذا يقول هذا
جزء الجزء الثاني نتكلم عنه من الجزء
الحيوي في قطاعات معينه
ليس من الجيد ان يكون في عده شركات تشتغل
فيه بسبب
حجم الاستثمار بسبب عدم توزيع المصاريف
وزاره المصاريف
ليش في السعوديه عندنا ثلاث شركات اتصالات
اسمع عندنا اربع خمسه سته سبعه عشره
وفي
ظهر ثلاثه واربعه افتراضيه ليفر وغيره
صحيح ليش مو موجود 20 شركه في الموضوع
الاقتصاديه في الشركات
20 20 من الالياف البصريه اللي تربط المدن
كل شركه راحت يكون عندها شركه البصريه
وابراج الاتصال الخاص فيها التكلفه
الاجماليه تكون كثيره على الجميع
شو يسوون ولا كوكي انا بحدد عدد الشركات
التي يكون موجوده وبراء قبل بتكون تحت
المراقبه
وبعطيها صلاحيات معينه
وبشروط معين يعني مثلا
برج اتصالات
بس جزء منها
على شركه الفلانيه والعلانيه
بسعر السوق ليش عشان يبنون
ف اي شركه
مجدي فاستبقى الشركات هذه السوق غير وجدي
والحكومه ما تقول لك لا ما تقدر تحصل لك
تعطي عشان تحصل الرخصه في مطلقات
كثيره اذا انت استوفيت جميع المطلقات
اذا انت ما تقدر
وما عندك القدره على الالتزام بكلها
الشروط شنو ما تقدر السعوديه
نفس الشيء البنك المركزي حط لك شروط معينه
اسوي لك بنك هذه الشروطي لازم تنزل فيه من
حجم كفاله راس المال العمش انه الخطه الى
اخره ليش لان لو
بسبب الترابط البنوك ما بينها وبينها لو
انهار اي بنك لاي سبب من الاسباب ما بيسبب
لك حاله الذعر
في امريكا
لانها المشاكل الموجوده في البنوك السيئه
خلينا نسميها
ما فيها شيء بس لان الخوف منها شيء انتشر
النظام البنكي بالكامل وادى فينا الى شنو
الاسواد
اقتصادي من ايام الكساد العظيم اللي صار
في
الثلاثينيات
القطاعات الحيويه يكون عليها رقابه اكثر
اشراف اكثر وشروط اكثر وتدخل الحكومي اكثر
اذا انت بتسوي لك
كوفي شوب ولا مطعم
شروط قليله
بسيطه
الى اخره اي حد يقدر يلتزم فيه
عدم وجود هذا المقهى ما باثر على الناس
بكره الشركات الاتصالات اللي عندنا لو
واحد ولا اثنين منهم
صار
في الحسبان
كبير كبير
من التشريعات اللي انا تبدا تنافس السوق
السعوديه يعني مش سعوديين الحكومات لين
ندخل موضوع التنافس المباشر يمكن ما بقول
هذا اللي هو الخط الاحمر ولكن هنا للامور
تبدو شويه
التنافس المباشر هل الحكومه خلينا ناخذ
السعوديه على سبيل المثال هل الحكومه
قعدتنافس القطاع الخاص في تاسيس مدينه
جديده
هل في قطاع الخاص قاعد يسوي جزر على البحر
الاحمر
لا المشاريع الكبرى القديه والى اخره هل
هي قاعده تنافس القطاع الخاص هل استنقطع
الخاص من عند القدره الماليه
لو بكره مثلا لو دخلت الحكومه وقالت خلاص
انا باخذ وكاله تويوتا ولا جي ام مسوي
احسن من بقيه الشركه بقول لك هاي لحظه
منافسه مباشره من القطاع الخاص
من السعوديه
ولكن ليس بالدرجه المطلوب والسيارات
الكهربائيه كانت موجوده في امريكا
اعطني اي نوع من الشركات اللي تقوم بها
اما الحكومه او الهايات الحكوميه وحتى
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه ولا واحده منهم
سنافس مباشره اي نوع من القطاع الخاص
منافسه مباشره طبعا اكيد بتجيب سيارات
كهربائيه
[موسيقى]
انا انا اسالك سؤال ثاني ليش نحن عندنا بس
منصه واحده للتداول في تشريعات تسمح
للقطاع الخاص بالنهايه
بالامن الوطني امريكا
نيو اكستراك
صغيره وكلها الامور ولكن امريكا
وحده اوروبا بالكامل عندها واحده
طيب عندهم منصات اصغر واصغر بس انت قاعد
في اقتصاد حجمه ان شاء الله بيكون طول
اليوم بنهايه السنه هل يلزمك يكون عندك
اثنين ولا ثلاثه
هم عندهم المعلومات هم اللي يقدرون يقررون
مثل الوقت المناسب يمكن هذا الشيء موجود
عندهم يدرسون انه اذا وصل يعني حجم
التداولات الموجوده الي عندنا عدد كبير
وعدد الشركات الموجوده عندنا تمثل
الاقتصاد ويحتاج انه يكون في عمق يمكن
نسويه فرصه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
اللي يحلل اهم احداث الكره السعوديه كسبنا
من خلال الاعتقادكم وتفاعلكم والمركز
الاول في كل حلقه الشيخ خلانا نطمح بنا
نتقدم خطوه
المونديال هو اكبر موسم ترامب من يوم ولدت
في الكوره قبل 150 سنه بدات فيه مسيرته
رونالدو
مثل زين الدين زيدان
عشان كده قررنا ناخذ خطوه جديده ونكون
معكم صوت وصوره في مونديال 2022 الحدث
النادر في كل شيء تقريبا هذه اول مره يقام
في بلاد عربيه هذه ايضا اول مره يقام
بتوقيت هنا الشتوي والاهم من ذلك ان هذا
المونديال هو بمثابه الرقصه الاخيره
بلاعبين عظيمين جدا بقيمه كريستيانو
رونالدو وليونيل ميسي راح نحلل معكم افكار
مدربين ونقف فيه على كل جمله
مع منتخب الوطني اللي بيشارك للمره
السادسه واحنا نستمتع كلنا جميعا باجواء
مونديال 2022 في طريقتنا اللي تعودتم
عليها وحبيتها كوب قهوه وسواليف بتحليل
الدقيق وارقام مستدله تابعونا في كاسده
على قنوات 8 كما نصرت البوتاس واليوتيوب
طيب ودي
ادخل على يعني الحين على الاقتصادات
العالميه بس قبلها
في المنطقه
الي اليوم واضح فيني منافسه شريفه وقويه
ومحتدمه بين الرياض ودبي
كيف تقرا مستقبلها
هل تقدر
[موسيقى]
اساسي
تنافس ما بين الدول
في المنطقه الواحده
خلينا نضع الاول
اقتصاد المملكه هو اكبر اقتصاد
في دول الخليجيه طبعا رقم اثنين هو
الامارات بعدين عندك رقيه الدول الخليجيه
الاخرى وهي صغيره
فعندك انت
اقتصاديا كل واحده فيهم انك قعدتنافس انها
تحاول انك تقدم شيء جديد
ولكن في نفس الوقت
الفرصه غير مو محصوره فقط ان انا اخذ منها
المدينه او هي تاخذ منها المدينه احنا مو
قاعد نتكلم عن وجود نقطتين ولا مجموعه
صغيره
فاللي تقدر تسويه مو بشرط انه انا اخذ من
دبي عشان انا انجح طيب ممكن انا اخذ
العالم كله يكون عندي على سبيل المثال هذه
النقطه النقطه الثانيه
نمو السعوديه في فائده العمارات
والنمو الامارات
الواردات السعوديه عن طريق البحر تجيء
اكثر من من جده الاسلام
الوردات طريقه ارخص الى المملكه
صحيح
بيستفيد من الحكومه تستفيد منها المواطن
ايضا
عليه
عبارات موجوده
طلب عقار او كافراد او الناس اللي تعيش في
البيت ايضا بيرتفع اسعار الفائده للجميع
انا بشكل فردي وشخصي احد المستفيدين
الاقتصاد السعودي
عمان
الامارات غير المشاريع خلال فتره راحت
السعوديه وعمان المشاريع قاعد يسوونها مع
بعض
ممكن قبل ما كانت تصير ولكن بسبب النمو
الاقتصادي السعودي
جيت من دبي او من البحرين الى الرياض
فهذا اخذكم من هناك الى هنا صحيح اه
ان معظم الشركات اللي موجوده في دبي
او الامارات
هي موجوده في في المنطقه لخدمه السعوديه
اقدر اقول انه بدون وجود اقتصاد السعوديه
يمكن يكون ما لها دفه وجودهم فاذا
انتقالهم من دبي الى الرياض
[موسيقى]
او الشركات اللي ممكن تتعاقد مع تركي
الشركات
حكوميه
العامه
ليس فقط السعوديه اسعار النمو في السعوديه
علشان الخدمه الاضافيه حق المملكه طبعا هل
20 موظف الزود اللي جرب بسبب ارتفاع الطلب
من السعوديه يمكن الشركه الموجوده في
البيت كل طيب انتم عشره منكم
روحوا الرياض في الرياض
[موسيقى]
القسم العمليات اللي ما يحتاج وجودهم يكون
موجود بالرياض على سبيل المثال خلاص
القسم العمليه ما يخدم فقط السعوديه يخدم
ايضا بقيه المنطقه التي دبي
المقر الرئيسي الى الرياض
من اي مكان صحيح
هل المفروض سن الي يصير نتكلم عنه شنو
حيثيات تعريف المكتب الرئيسي
على قلب بالنسبه لي انا مو واضحه عرفتها
عرفتها هل تقصد طيب اذا انا عندي على سبيل
المثال خلينا نقول انس شركه عندي 100 موظف
موجودين
10% من الخدمه لقدمها السعوديه طيب انا
احول احولهم كلهم للرياض متى احولهم
مباشره
هل اذا انا مثلا حولتهم كلهم بالرياض
وفتحت عشره موظفين همم في دبي يصير ولا ما
يصير او
العشره منهم الرؤساء
في الرياض سميها الهيد كوارتر بيكون عندي
100 موظف في دبي هل هذا التحقق ولا ما
تحقق اتوقع هذه الرؤساء
انتقاله
وهو تحدي الاكبر
طويل على الامد الطويل اخره الشركات اللي
بتشوف انه اغلب عمليات هي المملكه
وصارت في جوده الحياه الموجوده وفي المكان
واحد يقرر شركه بروح تقول طيب يعني كل
شغلي انا في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
فيقول لك
الى الرياض ويختم بقيه الدول اللي كان
يخدمها لان المسافه ما تعتبرها
الامور تتغير بشكل يومي صعب التنبؤ بجنون
بس من الناحيه العمليه من ناحيه العقليه
والمنطقيه
رياض ما تحتاج ان تكون مثل دبي حالا من
ناحيه جوده الحياه
العشه الموجوده كلها
قاعده تشتغل في اماكن اخرى في العالم مو
مثل الدبه راضيه ابو ظبي
قاعدين يشتغلون عادي حياه تمام ما عندهم
اي مشكله بحياتهم
كلهم
مدرسه جيده
عقارات رائعه يعني احيانا افكر في الرياض
بتخيل اني انا ملياردير خير الفندق
[موسيقى]
تحتاج الكميه التي بتطلبها اولا عمليا غير
منطقي انك تروح تبني كل لحظه تقدر تبنيها
على الفتره والحكومه
وشجع القطاع الخاص على موضوع البناء
والقطاع الخاص قاعد تشوف هذه الامور اللي
قاعده تتغير قاعد
في القطاع الخاص ليش القطاع الخاص عندنا
في الخليج يعني اضرب مثال في افضل شيء همم
اما عقار او امتياز لعلامات تجاريه بس ما
حد جالس يصنع
سيارات
مثلا
في الانتاج الصناعي في الصين
خلني اقول لك خلينا ناخذ همم السيارات
الكهربائي كمثال ابدا تبقى الاحصنه حتى
ههه كم تحتاج فلوس عشان تبني لك سياره
مصنع هيك انتاج سيارات الكهرباء
عندنا في الخليج ناس عندهم فلوس اكثر من
اللي عند الى الماسك يوم بدات تسلم
حتى الفلوس مثلا الحين تسلا اعلانات انك
بتحبني بنيه ولا ثلاثه
سوى عمليه التسويقين اطول من برج دبي
جاب من لان عند نظام راس مالي عميق فلوس
المستثمرين موجوده فلوس البنوك موجوده
[موسيقى]
على شان ابني
فاولن تحتاج القدر الماليه
بحيث انك تقدر تتكلم عن شيء بالمليارات ما
في احد عنده
حتى عندنا
الفلوس
انه مستعد انه يحط في مصنع هذا هو التحدي
الاول
تحدي
الثانيه طبعا مقارنه بامريكا واوروبا
والصين
كم عدد البنوك التي تقدر تروح ترتب لك
استثمار في مصنع
انتاج سيارات للكهربائيه تحتاج بالمليارات
قليل
فعندك التحديات من وجود الراس المال ومن
جامعه ولكن هذا ليس فقط التحدي النهائي او
الكامل تحدي الاكبر
لا انا بروح بابني سياره كهربائيه من
بشتري مني طبعا
87 يوم بدا تسلم
بعد مرور اكثر من 15 سنه
اليوم صحيح
خليجي يملكه
تقول هذا يا اخي
الراجحي
والنعم
ملابس جديده
سيارات سيارات
[ضحك]
لن قارن يمكن دائما
نروح نقول على سبيل المثاله
كره القدم في البحرين ممثل البرازيل
طويله
في عده امور لازم تكون
مشدي
[موسيقى]
تواجد تطبيق فكره
مهم جدا السوق كم السوق
[موسيقى]
انا انا وانت فكرناه
الشاحن لاسلكي
انا سوينا فكره شاحن لاسلكي تقدر تشحن في
اي شيء ان شاء الله الكاميرات وهاي موجود
خلاص ننسى الموضوع معنا
شيء الثاني الحصول على راس المال كبدايه
او راس المال الجريئه
في الاسواق المتقدمه عندها تاريخ وعندها
اليه معينه والفتره طويله تقدر تروح تاخذ
منهم الاموال اداره هذه الاموال
نحن عندنا يمكن الى الان في الخليج لو
ناخذ موضوع
[موسيقى]
فرنسي يحتفظ
قدرت على تنفيذ وعلى الاموال الفرصه
موجوده
خلينا نقول احنا كل الامور قضيناها عليه
وبدات الفكره قعدت تنجح او قاعد تنجح ان
اثبتت عمليات ولكن نحن خسرانين قاعدين
قاعدين نخسر الطريقه الوحيده نحول
هالخساره الى الربع ان الناس
الفكره طبقتها على سبيل المثال خلينا نقول
في البحرين
[موسيقى]
ايه عندنا المشكله انه انا اروح من
البحرين الى السعوديه
الانظمه تختلف اختلاف كبير
ولكن في اختلاف كبير
مجلس التعاون خففت من التحديات ولكن لا
تزال موجوده لازم انا انشر شركه اخرى
بالمقابله حتى عن طريق شركه البحرينيه
اقدر ولكن ليس الامر في اشتراطات معينه
بالسعوديه قد لا تكون موجوده في البحر
البحرين والعكس والعكس صحيح فيلزمني شنو
تاخير في الانتاج تاخير في الفكره
من دوله بحجم مليون شخص الى دوله 30 مليون
شخص
اوك حجم كبير ولكن على مستوى العالم 30
مليون ولا شيء قارن هاي لو انا سويت نفس
الفكره
في امريكا
صين ايضا نفس الفكره
تشوف جميع الافكار جميع الشركات اللي جايه
اخر 20 سنه اما الصيني ولا اتحاد اوروبي
او امريكي
حتى الموضوع لو تلاحظ ما في شيء ياباني
جديد
كوري جديد
فرنسي
[موسيقى]
تقدر تسويها 100 مليون او المئتين بسبب
الاسواق الموجوده هذا مجدي بس لو تروح
تقول لا ترى هالمليون تتعب تحط الجهد والى
اخرها يمكن يصير مليون واحد
على هالزياده زياده
موجوده
او حتى عربيه
لو نفك من لما اقول لك بشكل
كبير قول طيب خلينا نكون نحن عندنا منطقه
اقتصاديه متكامله ما بين الخليج مصر تركيا
حتى ايران عراق سوريا
[موسيقى]
كمل افكار تقدر تطلع حبيبتي تقدر تنتجها
لكم بكل بساطه ما عندك كل هذه التحقيقات
وهذا المفيد ليش الاتحاد الاوروبي قرر انه
يتحد ترى الاتحاد الاوروبي
اوروبي في ما بينهم سنوات والسنوات
ولكن بعد انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
من 45 الى اتفاقيه ماستر
خلال 30 40 سنه حطوا موضوع الوحده
الاوروبيه بحيث انه يقدرون يستفيدون
امريكا والصين
بيقول لك من الاكبر
يعني خطر يواجه امريكا الاتحاد الاوروبي
المتوسط
في الصين
موجود او تعليم الحديث الموجود في الدول
اوروبا على سبيل المثال
عندهم انتاج صناعي
عندهم القدر
من جديد
تطلع من الاتحاد الاوروبي من اكثر الناس
اللي شجعهن تطلع امريكا
واحنا بنساعدكم والى اخره
المشاكل اللي صار الحين في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ما بين اوروبا و روسيا على الرغم
من الحربي حرب اوروبيه روسيا في اوروبا
كلها اوروبا
امريكا
امريكا اللي قاعده تحب تدخل في الوضع
الاوروبي علشان اتاكد انه اوروبا
على المستوى المدى البعيد
دوله تقود اقتصاد العالمي
مش المعايده الو الناتج المحلي هل هو
تبادل الاقتصادي للقوه
كلها عسكريه بشكل اساسي
القوه العسكريه
تزيد القوه الماليه القوه الماليه تزيد
القوه العسكريه اللي عندك انت كيف تروح
تبني السفن بالطائره هذا ما عندك فلوس
المعروفه
السفن عدده كحجه موقع القدره العسكريه
الحربيه الامريكيه
تساوي
جميع دول العالم
عباس البحرين موجود
[موسيقى]
من محافظ على الجزء الشرقي لها يابان
كوريا الجنوبيه
تايوان فلبين طبعا في جنوب استراليا وعندك
جزر المحيط الهادي امريكا عندها قواعد
عسكريه في كل من هذه الدول
طيب كمل سفينه صينيه موجوده عند امريكا
في سفينه حربيه صينيه
مرت ما بين فلوريدا وكوبر
في الستيني
يقول لك
الصين قاعده عسكريه مثلا في كوبا لا طبعا
لا تسمع
على الاقل يمكن تدري ان فيه
ناس موجودين لهم متعلقين بالصيني في
التعاون ما بين
الحزب الشيوعي الكوبي مع الصينيين في
تبادل الاخره نعم ولكن
قاعده عسكريه بحريه ولا الجويه في كوبا
تابعه للصين
خارج المملكه خارج الصين جيبوتي
هذا المنطقه الوحيده اللي عندها سامحه
قبل لا تنسى اللي يفصل الامريكان عن باقي
العالم محيطين عندك وحيد الاطلسي والمحيط
الهادي ومحيط الهادي ومحيط امريكي لو تشوف
كل الدول الموجوده جزر الموجوده كلها
[موسيقى]
هذا اول شيء الشيء الثاني حجم الاقتصاد اي
احد عنده فكره جديده ولا يبي يسوي شيء وين
بيروح بيروح لامريكا
عدد من الشركات اللي كانت تبغى تنجح في
الدول العربيه
بسبب الكلام اللي انا قلت انه صعب النمور
بالنسبه لها هي كانت مقراتها الموجوده في
الدول العربيه وديتهم الامريكا من اجل
النمو
ممتازه جديده من اجل النمو
نجحت الشركات الخاصه
ارباح الحكومه الامريكيه او ايرادات
الحكومه الامريكيه
العسكريه
في القوه الاقتصاديه والقوه العسكريه
حصلت امريكا على الشيء يمكن ما في احد
عنده قوه الدولار
بسبب الاستقرار السياسي القوه الاقتصاديه
والقوه العسكريه لامريكا كثير من الدول
بدات تستخدم الدولار
من اجل التجاره البينيه في ما بينهم عندك
عمله مستقره ما تغير سعرها 20 بالميه خلال
ليله وضحاها في الدول اللي مثلا
شيء الى البرازيل ولا الارجنتين كلها يا
اخي انا ما بدي فلوس
البرازيلي
اصلا بفسكم
في ناس عندهم ثقه اكثر بالدولار فيتم
استخدام الدولار خارج امريكا الاغراض
للتجاره وايضا لاغراض الاستثمار
وبما ان الاقتصاد الامريكي رغم انه شكلهم
حوالي 10 سكان العالم او حتى اقل لكن
الحجم اقتصادهم 25% من اقتصاد العالم
بسبب هذا الشيء يكون في استثمارات اجنبيه
تردد هدولارات الاضافيه ساعد الاقتصاد على
النمو في نفس الوقت تحتاج يتم استخدام
عالميا في الموضوع يعني احنا بغض النظر
احنا كدوله موجوده في السعوديه هذا النظر
حتى لو عملتنا ما كانت مرتبطه بالدولار
خلينا نقول ما كنا
نقدر نطبع بنفس السهوله
مثلا
انت طبعا
بارتفاع كبير
2009 وفي مشاكل الكورون اللي صار
بالمليرات
حاطه في الاختصار عشان نساعد الاقتصاد في
النمو
بقيت الدول ما كانت تقدر تسوي شيء كان في
اللمت حتى بريطانيا
الصين ممكن تقدر تسوي تحدد اوروبي مشكله
اخرى
عندهم بس الدوله الوحيده التي تقدري تسوي
الشيء بقيه الدوامات ما تقدروا امريكا من
ناحيه
المليارات وسحبه وادارات
طيب اسمحي لي ناخذ واحده واحده
اليوم اختلاف التقاعد لعبه
فمثلا اليوم تايوان امريكا تم القاعده
العسكريه فيها
والصين اليوم
يعني تبي تتعامل مثل
كوبا امريكا لن تسمع اليوم الصين تشوف لنا
امريكا
بوشك الدخول للحرب يعني في هذا الموضوع
واضح ان الحرب
حيوان ما بين امريكا والصين
والطائرات
يعني الاجازه تصير دائما بشكل يومي على
تايوان فاعسكريا جسد اكبر جلسه ابني قواعد
طريق الحرير وكيف تبغى تكون لها تواجد في
كل الدول
او حتى في باكستان وايران وكل هذه الدول
في اليوم عسكريه ليست كما هي
ففي نمو
لصين وهي منتهى عسكريه على مستوى العالم
هذا صحيح في نمو الصين العسكريه والحتى
اقتصاديا الموجوده الحين تختلف عن الصين
كانت موجود قبل 20 ولا 30
سنه عده اسباب الاقتصاد
وتغيرات الاقامه بتردد حتى دوله النظام
الاقتصادي رايحين
لا تعتبر الدوله الشيوعيه هي تعتبر نظام
راسمالي وصبغه الشيوعيه ولا بالغلاف
الشيعي الطريقه
في العالم
ولكن تحديات اللي عندها اكبر من
تحياتنا نحن نقدر نشوفها انا اقول لك ليش
من ناحيه الاستراتيجيه
لو انت شوف ترى الصين
عندها مشاكل مع اليابان
عندها مشاكل مع كوريا
عندها مشاكل مع الفلبين عندنا مشاكل
جزء من اكيد تشجيع غربي يعني المشاكل وجزء
منه امريكا
[موسيقى]
ونفس الشيء الصينيين مع الكوريين الجنوبيه
عن سبيل على سبيل المثال
ليش عندهم مشكله
يعني
سريعا يعني اخر موعد للامبراطوريه اخر
السنه الامبراطوريه الصينيه كانت
1911 و1000 او 1912 وصارت الصين بعدها
جمهوريه الصينيه جمهوريه الصينيه وطنيه
الى نهايه الاربعينيات لان الدوله
الشيوعيه الثالثه والافراد الشيوعيين ثروت
استولى على الحكم والجمهوريه الصين
الوطنيه طلعت حرب من الصين
الحاليه تشوف التعبان
الفلول السابقه
في اوروبا
الالمان والفرنسي ينقتلوا بعض فتره طويله
المان احتلوا فرنسا في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والانجليز
يعني حاضر الحروب
في اتحاد ولا التوافق كبير في الراي ما
بين الدول الاوروبيه امريكا
ناخذها
وجابت فيه العالم جابر في امريكا
امريكا شمال امريكا
[موسيقى]
يكون عندك دول صديقه من ناحيه الاقتصاد من
ناحيه السياسه اسهل لك كثير في الاداره
لما يكون عندك دوله محاطه
ما بقول بالعداء دول عندك مش مشاكل معاهم
الافضل لو عسويني في ما بينهم يروحوا نشوف
متخيل لو مثلا كان في التكتل اقتصادي
اسيوي ما بين يابان وكوريا او الصين وبقيه
الدواجن
احبك مكون اقتصاد كبير يمكن اكبر بعد من
التعادل الاوروبي
وسيله من الوسائل ان هذه الدول
تتفق في ما بينها قواعد العسكريه الموجود
يسوون زوبه على موضوع تايوان
مع اليابانيين
طيب
العسكريه يعني اذا باخذ برضه الدولار
78 1970 كانت اصلا الناتج
العالمي الناتج المحليه 4 يعني 5%
اليوم وصل الى
50% الانتاج العالم
في نفس الوقت امريكي
اذا اخذنا الدولار والتعامل فصحيح ان
الدولار لا يزال الاكبر بس الدولار كان
همم
8% من اللي موجود عالميا 2001 اليوم
فهو يقل في نفس الوقت الصين جست تنمو ونمو
هائل جدا
[موسيقى]
فالواضع حتى كثير من الناس
في عام 20 و30 وتكون الصيني
الاكبر في العالم اقتصاد الاول في العالم
وفي همم برده يقول لك انه يوصل اقتصاد
السن ل 38 تلفزيون
امريكا
على التاريخ بس يقول انه الصين ستكون
الاقتصاد العالم الاول يعني
يمكن
احنا قاعد نتكلم على المستقبل البعيد صاحب
التنبؤ من احدى الطرق الناس اللي يسوونها
يعني
30 40 50 سنه صعب جدا انه العمل على
توقعات اقتصاديه بيانيه وممكن الارقام
توصل لان شو يسوون بهذه الطريقه في طريقه
الحساب بالارقام تشوفوني مثلا النصين زاد
حجم الاقتصاد 10% سنويا اخر 10 سنوات يلا
انا بقول ثمانيه بالمئه سنويه حق 20 ولا
30 سنه وامريكا ثلاثه بالمئه سنه طيب
والله تاخذ البحرين نفس المستوى بعد 100
سنه بصير اكبر من امريكا ههه
همم في بهاء المنظور في هل فعلا تقدر تنمو
بها السرعه ولها الفتره خلال الفتره
الزمنيه المعينه صعب تجاههم ولكن خلينا
نرجع الاساسيه الاساسيات اللي تقول ان
اولا لفتره السابقه اللي راحت اخر
20 ولا 30 سنه على المستوى التاريخي
العالمي هي فتره استثنائيه وليس رواق قصدي
انه الصين قاعد ترجع تاخذ موقعا من اقتصاد
العالمي
لو احنا ناخذ تاريخيا من يومها
الامور الصين كانت اكبر حجم اقتصاد الصين
والهند لفترات طويله وكان هذا الموجود حجم
اغتصاب بسبب عدد سكان الموجود بجميع انواع
البحوث حتى الغربين عملوها
بكل بساطه يعني الى القرن السادس عشر ولا
السابع
كانت اكبر دوله في العالم
بعدين حلقه بعض الامور اللي قلبت الايه
شويه
جزء من
السياسات الاستعماريه والسياسيه وجزء منه
الحصيده العلميه للدول الغربيه لو احنا
نشوف ناخذ الخط بنشوف حجم الاقتصاد الصيني
كيف كان يمثل كنسبه من الناتج العالمي
والدول الغربيه
2830 شوف انخفاض شديد
وهذه الصوره الصناعيه ساعدت على النمو
الاقتصاد مساعد على ثراء ان يكون موجود
وشيء الثاني
هي فتره
الاستفاده واستغلال من ثروات الشعوب
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني بحلول بداياتها قرن
التاسع عشر نقدر نقول
خلصنا من موضوع اكتشاف امريكا الشماليه
امريكا الجنوبيه ربي يفعلهم موجود في
الهند
جميع الملاحه
طرق الملاح العالميه
وكان في استغلال البشع يعني يعطيك على
سبيل المثال موضوع حرب الاثيون
التعرف عنه ولا لا
حرب الافيون كان على حربين في منتصف 1830
للاربعين وال 50
بريطانيين كانوا يبون يستفيدون من الخدمات
القدم
[موسيقى]
الاستهلاك المحلي لان عندك
طلب على المنتجات الصيني
بس الصيام كان عندها ايه اهتمام الاشياء
الي اوروبا عندها كصدير شنو يكون
الانجليزي يعطونهم ذهب والفضه مش اكثر انا
اعطيك ذهب والفضه علشان البي
الزياده اللي قاعده تصير في ديرتي في
اوروبا
بنفس الطريقه ترى بخلص
شنو بدها تسوي الحكومه البريطانيه عبر
الشركات الموجوده
تروح تنتج الافيون
في الهند
طيب كيف تقنعهم بالطريقه الحلوه ولين
الامبراطور الصيني قال
لا ممنوع خلاص انا
حرق
المصانع والمستودعات الانجليزيه الموجوده
في الصين اللي فيها الغربيه
لعبه جميع البواخر
في العاصمه في الصين عن طريق الراحه عن
طريق الانهار وصلت هناك سبب سوت حصان
واعلنه الحرب عليها لما الحكومه الصينيه
او الامبراطور الصيني
فصار الفتره
يعطون الشعب الافيون حق عشرات السنين
الناتج الصيني
عندهم مشاكل ناس ما كانت تشتغل
على هالموضوع
الدول الاوروبيه تستغل خيرات البلد
لو تشوفها الفتره نرجع في خلالها الفتره
بسبب الثوره الصناعيه صارت في اوروبا بسبب
الحروب اللي كانت سنه هذه الدول الغربيه
بسبب تفوقها العسكري على الصين
وبعدين طبعا عندك الحرب العالميه الاولى
اجت في الصين بعدين الاحتلال الياباني
للصين والمشاكل الشيعيه بعد حتى الشيوعيين
اساوي اداره البلد
سبب المجاعه في الخمسينيات والستينات لين
في السبعينيات
الطبقه الحاكمه في الصين تعيد الترتيب
اولوياتها واذا التركيز يكون اكثر على
الاقتصاد في حزتها اللي كانت تكلم انت
عنها ما بقول الثوره الصينيه الاقتصاديه
ولكن بدا النمو
كانت عليه تاخذ دورها
المركز الاول المركز الاول
متى بيكون هذا المركز الاول هل امريكا
بتظل ساكته بحيث انه يكون في تفوق صيني
عليها
طبعا
في عده امور صراع قاعد تجري حاليا في
الاغتصاب
خصوصا في التقنيه اكبر اوجه الصراع
الاقتصادي هو الحين في التقنيه
تحتاجه في الصناعه اشياء كثيره في العالم
ثمانين بالمئه من التصنيع الهرموات تاتي
من اسيا
الصين كوريا واليابان
2012 فقط
البداوي الحين يستخدمون على هذا الشيء
الثاني موضوع التقنيه والذكاء الاصطناعي
بدايه تدخل فيه قوه
ان يعطيك مثال
علي بابا
[موسيقى]
للناس المستخدمين
علي بابا وعندك شركات السيارات الكهربائيه
الصينيه اللي قاعد تطلع في توجه كبير من
الصيع الموضوع التقنيه وفيه صراع امريكي
صيني على موضوع التقنيه حتى في
براءات الاختراع عدد الشركات منافسه شديده
ما بين الصين
[موسيقى]
واحد من اول او او الثاني يوم والثاني
جدا
في الدول الاوروبيه كانت اثبتها مرتفعه
لكن
الاتحاد الاوروبي
لو ناخذ اتحاد الاوروبي مضمون الالماني
والفرنسي والايطالي بعيد جدا في موضوع
التقنيه
فالحين الصراع الصيني الامريكي من غير
موضوع العسكري العسكري واضح الحين الى
الان امريكا هي المتقدمه
بفارق كبير عن الصينيين وهذا التقدم يمكن
20 30 40 سنه بكون عندها
الصين في الموضوع
اللي تعملها ذكر في البدايه كانت اتكلم
شنو دور الدوله دور الدوله في الصين
تروح تتدخل ولكن
التوجه الدوله
[موسيقى]
التنفيذ
كرتون على المقطع الخاص
على الاقاليم الصينيه
كل اقليم
في امريكا تقول انا عندنا توجه حق اشباه
الموصلات بعدين كل الولايه
تنفذوا ولايه الثانيه في تطبيق
ولايه اقليم
اقعد اقليم معين قاعد ينجح نجاحك هذا
الموضوع ونتعرف انت نجحت علم بقيه الناس
بقيه الاقاليم بقيه الولايات كيف يتم
تطبيقها
فيختلف عن امريكا يختلف عن الاتحاد
الكبيره
وكيفيه تطبيقها على المستوى المحلي
امريكي او شركه امريكيه التعامل مع اي احد
يشبه الممثلات وغيره لدرجه انه اي امريكي
عندي خيار لما يكمل شغله وتسحب الجنسيه
اشاره الى
قرب الصين من
التقدم الامريكي ولا
من هالناحيه اعتقال في الموضوع التقنيه
الامريكان والصينيين راس براس
كبيره
حتى في
سياقه الذاتيه عند الاستثمارات كبيره قاعد
تعمل فيه وقريب لما تعمله امريكا امريكا
متقدم اكثر في الموضوع الروبوت
التقنيه
ولكن اجمالي عدد البحور كعدد الجامعات
التقنيه والى اخره لا تزال افضليه افضليه
امريكيه
جدا
طيب اليوم انا بتكلم عن سبع سنين
هل الصين تسوق الامريكي
في
عندك
واحد من اهم صناديق التحول يقول ان
المستقبل المشرق للصيف
وان الصين ستسوق الامريكي
والمستقبل مشرق صحيح لان اللي بيكون بيطلع
من دول اسيويه بيكون افضل من الماضي
[موسيقى]
الصين حق فتره طويله كانت امها 10% 8 9 8
9 10
[موسيقى]
خلاص
البحرين البحرين
[موسيقى]
اعاده كيف اعاده
التركيز
الطبق الحاكمه انه خلاص قلنا قبل شوي
ليس الموضوع موضوع اقتصادي بحث مثل ما كان
موجود
في التسعينيات
نصير لم تكن ابد في اي نوع من اي صراع
كانت بحالها ولا كلمه ولا همسه في الموضوع
وما تتدخل في الامور الداخليه لاي دوله من
الدول ولا حتى المساعدات تركز على الشغل
فهذا معناه ان كل القوه الدوله المركزه
على شيء واحد الحين فتره اللي راحت اللي
كان فيه انخفاض معدل النمو
بدات امور استراتيجيه تدخل ضمن حزبان
الدوله اللي ما كان فيها موضوع
استراتيجيه سياسيه وعسكريه
الحين عنده اهميه موضوع مهم جدا بالنسبه
لها موضوع الجزر والملاح اللي قاعد تسويها
في المحيط الهادي وبقيه الدول كل هذا
بيكون له تاثير على نسبه النمو الاقتصادي
يعني اولويات
الحزب الحاكم تغيرت
خلال اخر خمس سنوات ولا عشره سنوات
نعمه في الاقتصاديات كانها ما بتسوي شيء
لا بتسوي لك مشاكل بتسوي لك حط لك العوائق
تركز على نفسها واسوي لك المشاكل مثل ما
سوت لو ابسط مثال اخر لك لو انا غلطان
يتكلمون على موضوع الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع النمو والى اخره وتضيف مع
بريطانيا اكبر من امريكا
[موسيقى]
بتعالج مشاكل
براحه وتفترض ان الدول الاخرى ما تدخل في
شؤونك الداخليه
في الصين وعندنا قلت لك الصين يمكن
افضل من امريكا ولكن يوجد نظر الشخصيه انه
لازم تنمو عن طريق حلفاء من حليب الصين
يعني ايه
ما ادري اذا في حديث بعينه بس اغلب الدول
اللي محيطها فيها تعتبر دول صديقه يعني
الى هنا الى السعوديه
يكون عندك مثلا العلاقه الاستراتيجيه ما
بين السعوديه والامارات السعوديه ومصر
السعوديه والاردن
يعتبر هذا الحديث
في امريكا كندا دول اوروبيه الثانيه
اليابان هذا الحديث بس اذا عندك انت
علاقات اقتصاديه مع الدول
عندك صديقه
كمنطقه جغرافيه ما عندها باستثناء كوريا
الشماليه كوريا الشماليه
كل الدول المحيطه اللي عندها عندها مشاكل
عندها مشاكل مع الهند مع اليابان
[موسيقى]
قريبين من بعض روسيا
حديثه الكبير بلا روسيا
حتى علاقتها مع عصير ما علاقت كويسه
الهند
مشاكل
بس عندها مشاكل ايضا غير برازيل
كلهم يكرهونا في امريكا الجنوبيه
جنوب افريقيا محافظ
[موسيقى]
بس تقريبا اكثر ولا اقل الحين طبعا هو
فكرتهم انهم احنا مثل
اوروبيين قبل 50 سنه 40 سنه في المستقبل
هاي بتغير ولكن وجهت النظر الموجود
الاستراتيجيين تخفيف اختلافات كبيره ما
بين الصين وروسيا والهند خلينا نخليهم
برازيل وجنوب افريقيا طرف منزلين الثلاثه
هم الاكبر اقتصاديات او مؤثرين بس ضعيفه
اقتصاديا ولكن مؤثره عسكريا موجوده
شنو وجهه النظر الي يقدر ينسون فيما بينهم
ما في على شان الصين ان تكون الدوله قويه
اقتصاديه بعد 20 ولا 30 40 سنه لازم نشوف
منظور من منظور
عالمي وليس من المنظور محلي لازم تحل
خلافاتها مع الصين مع اليابان تحل
خلافاتها مع الهند الخلافاتها مع كوريا
الجنوبيه والى خرا بحيث ان النمو الصين
يفيد بقيه الدول والنمو
لنتحل هالمشاكل السياسيه اللي عندك بحيث
انك انت تراوي الناس كدوله انت ما بتروح
ما عندك هنيه وترى هذا الشيء الصين
عارفينها حتى الموضوع
حق الانجليزي
حلفاء في سريلانكا
حلفاء في امريكا الوسطى
دول فقيره غير قادر لا سياسيه ولا
اقتصاديا ولا عسكريا
لان بقيه الدول
[موسيقى]
الشباب الامريكي
لو قطع كانت افضل حرب
دخلت في امريكا
قتلوا بعض وحرقوا بيوت بعض بعد ما انتهاء
الحرب قالوا لحظه فنان
مو لازم نحن نتعمد ونعاقبهم ونكمل هل
الاشياء خلينا ننظر المنظور المنظور كامل
الامريكا لان احنا قاعدين
ننافس اوروبا اللي حزلتها اوروبا هيك كانت
منطقه العسكري وتجاري واغتصادي الي كانت
متحكمه في العالم
فهي اللي كانت نظراتهم احنا نشوف هناك
حتى المؤسسين الامريكان والقادر والرؤساء
الامريكان كان عندهم حواس انه يكبون حجم
الاقتصاد الامريكي ويكبرون الحجم امريكي
كانت في البدايه 13 مستعمره امريكيه شوي
شوي عسكريه عن طريق تحاله حتى عن طريق
شراء الاراضي تمددت الى الغرب الى المحيط
الهادي
بالكامل من الفرنسيين سنه
[موسيقى]
ولكن عسكريه
جدا من اسيا مفيده نفس الشيء
لو الامريكي
[موسيقى]
مشاكل والعقبات والصين اتجاهات المشاكل
اللي تواجه امريكا اليوم في الخلافات
والاستقطاب السياسي الداخليه
في الجزائر الجزء الاول
[موسيقى]
الاعلام الامريكي في ما يتعلق بشان
الداخلي
يصيح ويصرخ اكثر من الم الحقيقه
انت بتقرا الاخبار وكلها الامور تحس انه
امريكا في حاله غليان يمكن ليله وضحاها
تصير حرب وهذا غير صحيح بعيدين جدا على
هذا الموضوع في تاجير من الناحيه الاسباب
سياسيه وانتخابيه ولا الى اخره في تاجيش
لهذه الامور
هذا الشيء الاول الشيء الثاني
ما في شيء امريكا دخلت في اسواق من الحرب
العالم من الحرب الاهليه الي هي دخلت فيه
يمكن هذا اسود وامريكا بحياتها مرت بحالات
اسوا بكثير داخليا من موجود حاليا على
سبيل المثال امريكا الى 60
كانت سرعه مال الشغب والى اخره وكان هذه
يمثل في السبعينيات صارت المشاكل
معكم ضد الحرب
في امريكا دائما تدخل ما في ولد اولى
عندها مناعه ضد المشاكل الداخليه هل عندك
الاليه بحيث انك تحل هذه المشاكل وما تسبب
هذا المشاكل الى حرب اهليه شامله نعم
امريكا هذه موجوده
ما عاجبك رئيس الولايه تقدر تنتخب البدله
ما عجبك التشريعات الموجوده عندك انتخابات
حق مجلس النواب عندك انتخابات حجم مجلس
الشيوخ يصير كل السنتين تقريبا
رئيس الدوله اربع سنوات المدلله اربع
سنوات ثاني خلاص معلش
مو عاجبك كلها الامور عندك مشكله عندك
المحاكم تقدر
في حالات
قتل الصين بسبب السلاح الى اخره ولكن
المشاكل اللي مرت فيها امريكا
مشاكل مرت فيها اقدام من هذا الشيء من
ناحيه الحروب هي مستقره
دوله مستقره سياسيه
مستقره اجتماعيا بغض النظر على كلام اللي
قاعدين يقولونه
وناجحه اقتصاديه
هذا والله اعلم على الاقل بيستمر عشر سنين
والعشرين سنه ما قلنا ما نقدر نتوقع اكثر
من 20 سنه صعب جدا
[موسيقى]
متهمون بعض بالخيانه والى اخره من هذا
الكلام
قبل ما يوصل الموضوع معاك
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
ضد امريكا الشفافيه الموجوده عنده
احنا نعرف كل هالمعلومات نعرف اراء
السياسيه من اعضاء المجلس من الشيوخ مجلس
النواب نعرف
حكام الولايات نعرف اراء الاقتصاديه نعرف
نعرف بالضبط شنو
اجتماعات البنك الاهلي الاحتياطي المركزي
طبعا خمس سنوات لكن بعد خمس سنوات
انا فلان قال ههه
ثم اتكلم
لا الكلام اللي قاعد بالكلام اللي انا
قاعد اقول مع تعتع اذا كانت موجوده مع
الضحكه يكتبونها موجوده للعامه اي احد
تقدر تروح انت تروح اخر 30 40 سنه يتكلمون
عنه
في البنك المركز الصيني
يمكن يمكن ايه يمكن لا ما تقدر تقرر ما
عندك اي فكره طيب كيف يروحون تاخذون
القرارات فيما يتعلق بالخطط الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه والاستراتيجيه
هنعرف
طيب هل هذا يحسب لصالح الصين
من الناحيه الي نحن نشوفها عالميه والله
انا عارف امريكا بالضبط
[موسيقى]
الاعلام العربي
طيب هذا شيء ممكن ناخذ بالشكل النسبي
انه الاعلامي يكبرها ويصغرها او هذه حقيقه
اللي مو بالنسبه للارقام فاذا اخذنا
الارقام اليوم امريكا عندها حجم الدين
ضخم جدا وكل شهر عن شهر وكل سنه يزداد
ياسر انه الاقتصاد كبار الارقام من بعض في
الناتج احنا بنقول فائض وهذولاك حجم
اقتصادهم
تريليون وهذول 30 تريليون لا يعني كل
مالهم يقربون وهذا 18سنه 23 ترليون وعفوا
يعني تقدر تشوفهم
الاقتصاد
الدين فلوس
[موسيقى]
سلاح ذو حدين
وايضا
للدول الناشئه
بتعتمد على الاستثمارات الخارجيه او على
الاموال الخارجيه
ولكن الدول الاساسيه اللي هي اليابان
امريكا والصين وبعض الدول الاوروبيه
تقدر الامريكي
كيف كيف يفلسون كيف
عندك تريزيونات من الدولارات انت اصدرتك
سندات الخزينه
اسوء الاحوال
[موسيقى]
السعوديه الحين اعتقد 30 ولا 34% فقط 120%
كم اليابان
240%
[موسيقى]
مشكله بطريقتها منخفاض في عدد السكان والى
ولكن موضوع اخر
نرجع موضوع الدين فاولا موضوع الدين ليس
بالسوق
ارتفاع من 60% الى 110 امريكا بتنفجر
امريكا
[موسيقى]
اصلي 60%
ونفس الشريف في الايام
التسعينيات بدايه الالفيه اذا انا ماني
غلطان
[موسيقى]
ما كانت في سندات الخزينه
الولد الولد عسكري
رهيب فرجع
غير الفائض الى الى عجز هو هو السؤال هو
هذا العجز اللي عندك في الميزانيه وهذه
الديوك
الاساسيه شنو وجهه نظر المستثمرين لانه
عندك خطه سليمه لان عندك
شيء واضح في شفافيه
المستثمر مشاكل
[موسيقى]
رئيسه الوزراء السابقه قالت اعلنت عن خطه
خفض الضرائب
وزياده المعونات حق الطاقه والى دعم
للطاقه طيب معناه
حكومه والله
[موسيقى]
امريكا الى الان لا واضح ان في نمو
اقتصادي معدل البطاله منخفض تضخم قاعد
شويه شويه قاعد ينخفض جميع الدلائل تشير
ان هذه مشكله مؤقتا وليس مشكله دائما
العائق الاول عندك كيف تقدر تثق بهذه
الارقام اللي عندك في ناس كثير صحيحه
لان لا تخضع لاي دراسه وغير واضحه ما
يعطون المعلومات ما نعرف نقدر نقارنها هل
هي صحيحه ولا غير صحيحه اولا لازم نفترض
ان ارقام هي فعلا
[موسيقى]
عندهم تحديات مختلفه تحدي بتستمر
واذا كانت افكار هم خاطئه بسبب مركزيه
القرار 8 قد يكون باهظ على الاقتصاد
فلن نقارن هذه الامور الموجوده في الصين
او حتى في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي امريكا
النظام
كل واحده منهم فيها ايجابيات وفيها سلبيات
الايجابيه مثلا في الناحيه الصينيه اذا
كانت الفكره سليمه
وصحيحه
الاقاليم الثاني
من ناحيه امريكا علشان يسوون لك تشريع خاص
بالنظام شيء لازم موافقه
الاعضاء يسموا لهم قانون ويمشي في المجلس
الشيوخ او مجلس النواب وبعدين عقل الشقه
الثاني من الكونغرس لازم يوافق عليها رئيس
رئيس الدوله مثل ما يوافق ويرجع يقول لك
مشروع القانون سنوات
يدرسونا ويحسبونا والى اخره ويمكن بعد
يوافقون عليه وما يتم تنفيذ واذا تم تنفيذ
هل تم تنفيذ بالطريقه الصحيحه ولا لا يمكن
بعد نخلص فتره الرئاسيه وقانون العلمي مصر
اصلا
ادي احدى
يسمونه سلبيات للنظام الامريكي
في ايجابيات ما قلنا للنظافه لكن النظام
معين شنو هو الافضل يعتمد على الدوله
يعني الحديث
عن امريكا عن الصين طويل او ممتعه
وفي حلقه كامله عن كيف تشتغل امريكا في
القوانين ادري انه معقب جدا اااه الحلقه
وعن الحرب الصينيه الامريكيه التقنيه حلقه
يعني اكثر ما كنت تتوقع اهتمام الناس همم
بالحرب الامريكيه الصينيه بس برده واضح
انها فيها تمام بتكون موظفه الحلقه العقاب
واحد
الواحد الان في الرياض يشتري ولا
يعتمد عليك انت تبي تستعجل
الاسعار في الرياض
[ضحك]
صعب يعني ما اتخيل اي احد بيروح
بالتلفزيون يروح بيقول لك ترى اسعار رخيصه
روحوا
مسؤوليتك لان بعدين كلام لان
صعب انه واحد يطلق الكلام
اسعار رخيصه روحها واشتروا كل شيء
الاسعار غاليه
النصائح اللي تكون
جماعيه وتكون الجميع
غير ممكن
99% يلا 90 بالميه
ما ادري
غير مناسب لهم
خلي واحد ناقص واحد مثلا هو بالرياض ولكن
حكم انتدابه للعمل كل سنه وسنه يودونا
مدينه مدينه
22 سنه
ليش لا وليش ايه هنتكلم كثافه استثمار
استثمار خارج النقاشه في ناس تروح تشتري
لك انا بروح بشتري عشان اجره
خارج نطاق الموضوع تملك السكن خارج ان
الطاقه الاجتماعي
اغنيه
انا مره
على موضوع ضعف القدره الشرائيه
حكم احب التاريخ احب القراءه
جميع بحث عن جميع المقالات الصحفيه تتكلم
عن القدره الشرائيه حق 10 سنوات 12 سنه
راحت
كل سنه من هذه السنوات
طبعا صحف تنقل عن خبراء ان في ضعف القدره
الشرائيه لدى المواطن
ومعقوله
كيف يكون عندك ضعف القدره الشرائيه لكل
سنه من هالسنوات 12 سنه في نفس الوقت قاعد
يرتفع
هذا الكلام غلط
او بس ان هذا الكلام المختصين ليس كلام
المختصين في عده احتمالات انك تروح
بس اراضي في كل مكان
45% الى الحين
في مساعده في تمويل تغيير نظام الاسكان
وهذا خلي الناس تقدر
والارتفاع برضو ان الحكومه ممسكه كثير
فتلقى الارتفاع كثير في الرياض اكثر من
مدن الثانيه يمكن رياضه جدا
في اماكن في الرياض لان هذا الموضوع ان
الارتفاع انه حصل هذا صحيح هذا المستوى
المملكه
ولكن كيف نقدر نحدد هل هو فوق القدره
الشرائيه ولا لا انا اقول
موضوع البيانات العامه هاي تحتاج لها
دراسه وفحص اكثر بس انا كلام انه يكون
للشخص الفرق الفرد نيجي يقول لي اشتري ولا
اجر كل عليك انت كيف شنو العوامل اللي
تساعدك خلينا نقول الموضوع
واحد يقرر اولا هل انت
ثبت نفسك اجتماعيا
اذا انت شاب 24 23
تروح البيت حياتي
[موسيقى]
مو بشرط نوع المنزل تبغيه انه يكون مناسب
مناسب لك حق 30 40 50 سنه
فقط
[موسيقى]
هذه اول شيء من ناحيه الثاني من ناحيه
الموضوع النمو لان المدينه قعدت تنمو في
النمو ما راح مو مراحل اماكن النمو قاعده
تتغير بشكل كبير يعني مثلا
البطحه
كانت عامره بالناس
وبسط الرياض لو تروح هناك وسط الرياض في
شواغر كثير
الدائره الشمالي قبل عشر سنين ولا 15 سنه
كان اعتبرونه بر من فوق دار الشمال
التغيرات تصير كثير
في فوائد للايجار في فوائد التملك فوائد
الايجار
مقارنه
بالراتب اقل من التقاء هذا اول شيء يعطيك
حريه التنقل
الجيرانك ما عجبك المنطقه شغلك قبل كنت
تشتغل هناك شغلك
رحمه المشاكل اذا عندك مشاكل مع اييه قال
نفسي تكون تحت رحمته طبعا يقول لك تغير بس
كل ما كبرت عائلتك صاحب اذا انت شاب بروحك
انت ولا زوجتك شخصين شنو نقشكم تطلعون سهل
[موسيقى]
صغير ثلاث اربع سنين قبل ما يروحون الجامع
هذا المناسب انك تشتري بيت
انك تفكر انك تشتري بشكل جدي البيت يكون
مناسب لك
والبيت الشكل المثالي انه بس عشره سنين
قدام يعني على الاقل انه يكفيلك
فكرونا انتم
يمكن
الله ما اعطاكم الى واحد ولا اثنين لي سبب
من الاسباب
الدراسه ولكن بعد اقتناع
لا تمشي وراءنا بس لان محمد
شريف لا تستعجل خذ خذ وقتك في فائده انك
تشتغل غير انك ما تشتري خلاص هذا بيتك انت
اي فلوس بتحطها انت بتستفيد منه
نوع من الراحه النفسيه يعني شيء بسيط جدا
وعندك الجدران خربانه
نفسي يمكن ما تحسه غير انك ترجع من الدوام
للبيت عارف انه حبيتك حلو وما في شخابيط
على جدران ما فيها تشققات ولالى اخره
يعطيك الراحه النفسيه هذه القيمه ايضا
اقول لك اعتمد على الشخص كل واحد يشوف
وضعه لان انت استقريت نفسيا وعمليه بدايه
حياتك هذا هو الوقت المناسب انك تشتري طيب
اجمع فلوسي واشتري
اقترب
والله لاغلب الناس لازم تقترب الناس عشان
تشتري
اجيب المبلغ
[موسيقى]
الاستخاره هذا اول شيء او الرغبه او حتى
يمكن
يحتاجون ينتظرون 15 سنه 20 سنه
[موسيقى]
الفلوس خلال الفتره قصيره
تيجي تشتري فيهم بيت موجود الحين
من البنك ومليون تخلي المليون هذه
الاضافيه
اذا عندك مليون وحده بس ما عندك مليون
الثانيه تاخذ تمويل عقاري
اذا عندك المليونين
تخليهم كاش
وتستثمر
اقول لك ليش لان
تاخذ التمويل العقاري يسبب لك نوع من
الالتزام المالي انت غصبا عليك كل شهر
لازم تدفع للبنك
صحيح
وانت يا انسان
خطوط احنا اللي عندنا العاده النا كل واحد
يحب يدير استثمار بنفسه ما عند الخبره وما
عندها هاي يقول لها انا بروح اعرف اختار
الاسهم بروح يدخل بطريقه عشوائيه اختيارات
الاسهم بعدين يقول اهلك ما اقدر ابي 60
[موسيقى]
فلو استثمارته في اي شيء اخر حاجه اللي
يسقك الراجحي كم كان العائد حقه خمسه ونصف
في المئه
الفائده
20 سنه
اول خمسه سنوات
على 10 سنوات
فهمت عليه لو كان في نوع من الضمان على
هذا الشيء مثلا لو انت قلت لي على سبيل
المثال انت ماخذ قرض من مصرف الراجحي 20
سنه اثنين ونص بالميه
في صكوك الراجحي سابته 5% حق 20 سنه
على هذا الموضوع لكن هذه الامور نادره
نادره
وهذا جزء من الجزء الثاني من المعادله
تخايب بعيد فلان فلان ما عنده قرض عند
التزام بعد يدفع البنك
عند استثمارات في الاسهم لك يوم من الايام
[موسيقى]
فلوس الراتب اللي بيجيك شو بتسوي فيه
تروح تستهلك بتروح بتنفخ بالاختصار
شنو معناته انه بيكون نمو اقتصادي منخفض
اسعار نموذج
عن شركه خاصه
اشتر لان انت مطمئن اللي عملك
وتمويل هو اخر
الخيرات الموجوده امامك وليس الخيار الاول
اذا انسدت عليه كل البيبان مو عندك 65%
[موسيقى]
المطر
يعني
يعطيك العافيه الله يخليك شكرا لك شكرا
لكم شكرا لتركي القحطاني ايمن ال الحمادي
في اعداد الحلقه الهندسه الصوتيه عبد
العزيز المزيد وبيع الدين المدني تحرير
جميل عبد الاحد وساعد في الانتاج الاصيل
وموسى مديرا للتصوير ومصور
القرشي في تصميم الاستديو هذا فنجان احد
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع ينشر
كل الانتاج الحب من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع
المقبل
[موسيقى]
الله يعطيك العافيه
[ضحك]
هناك في الاتكال تكتب في ارقام واضحه تفكر
في قبل ما تتكلم تتكلم وهو موجود للابد في
الارض
[ضحك]
انا غلطت في الكلام اللي بقوله مثلا سنوات